We'd love to hear tips for moving to
wake up earlier alarms and not disturbing
your spouse. Keeping alert throughout the
day. You know, when you wake up early,
this is, these are,
yeah, these are things.
So tips for managing the implications
around making that change to get up
earlier while keeping the space or the
keeping the speed or keeping the peace at
home and work and work. He work.
He either made a typo or he's, he's
on the inside. Shit. What that is,
is that's an homage to the
Portuguese accent. Yes.
It's a homage to the fake Portuguese
accent. No, it's the real one.
Worki well,
anything adding like e at the end,
like it'll come out. Oh yeah. Yeah.
It can be exaggerated though by
certain people, myself included. Yeah.
Okay. So, so how to wake up
in the morning, number one,
let's, let's talk about, oh,
one important piece of this. How do you
do it without disturbing the spouse?
Because we don't wanna we don't
wanna make the spouse angry.
No adversarial relationships with
this bus at four 30 or four 30.
So one of the things, real, real easy, one
out of the gate get an escalating alarm.
So what that means is it starts off
quiet. Sure. And it gets louder.
It gets progressively louder.
I am a much lighter sleeper than my wife.
So this is not that big of a deal to me.
And I can't answer,
but I've, I've, I've slept with
roommates at wanting to sleep, you know,
like in the military, you know, you got,
you got bunked together or whatever.
So I've dealt with this a little bit,
but it's really no factor.
Did an escalating alarm. And then
when that thing goes off, um,
you wake up before it gets
too loud to wake your spouse,
it should be on your side of the bed so
you can make it happen or you can pick a
song that starts off nice and
mellow and that kind of builds.
And for a long time, for this
particular reason, I used to have,
um, there's a band called the sword. Sure.
And they have a song called Iron Swan.
And it starts off nice and mellow. And
if you don't get up in time, it's common.
So you got it.
So it's like a Kinda like a game within
the game right there where you got to
beat the clock too. Yes. Yes.
You gotta beat the clock.
You've got to get up and turn that thing
cause otherwise it's an event and then
you're too late. What is it? Black
Swan? No Iron Swan. What's the source?
Yeah,
cause there's,
there's times in my life where I will put
like the ultimate shocker of a tune in
my,
um,
in my playlist that if I need to get
up and I need to get up and get on it,
like there's a song called re
repeat process by 100 demons.
That song will get you out of bed. It
will get you out of bed. When it kicks in,
it just comes, it comes to,
it's like, it's like getting,
it's like an explosion happens in your
room and it's a great song by a great
band. But anyways, so if,
but in this case you don't want
to go with a hundred demons. No,
you don't want to go
with repeat po process.
You want to go with the sword
iron song or on escalating alarm.
Now once you do that,
you kind of have the gear pre-staged
the gear has the morning gear has to be
pre-staged so,
so we're not in the dressing,
we're not pulling open drawers are not
flipping on lights are not searching for
stuff. No, we get up, we walk out of
the room. Yeah, quietly. Stealth mode.
Then you get to either the bathroom.
Now if you have the bathroom on sweet,
maybe you have some stuff staged
in the other bathroom in the house.
So you just walk right out of the room,
shut the door and you're good.
You made your escape, you know. Oh
and I'll tell you another thing,
little heads up.
Make sure that you set off your secondary,
I mean that you turn off your
secondary and your tertiary alarms.
So if you're like me and you
sleep with multiple alarm clocks,
if you leave cause they go
off sequentially, right.
You know you've got your first one iPhone,
then you've got your
second one battery powered,
or then you get your third one wind up.
The windup is the gnarly last
one with the [inaudible]. Right,
right.
If you leave that thing,
if you forget to shut that
thing off before you walk
out, you can hear about it.
You hear about,
cause now when it goes off,
it's a startle duller cause it doesn't
go off. I mean most of the, you know,
50% of the time I'm up before the alarms
but, but if you leave that one on there,
it's a starter and then then your,
your spouse's waking up in a panic mode
because now they don't know where it is.
There's effort, they're being attacked.
It's, it's, it's a gnarly situation.
So shut off the secondary and tertiary
alarms and then get out of the room and
then you know,
maybe even have your toothbrush and
your toothpaste staged and another in
another bathroom or in the kitchen
or whatever. Get your workout gears.
Not in a drawer by the bed where you're
pulling that open, making that racket. No,
you just get up and
you leave. So then, um,
that's, that's how you do it.
That's how I do it. And again,
I have an advantage because my
wife is a pretty heavy sleeper.
She gets mad that when I come home
from a trip and late at night,
I do some unpacking in the night.
That can be a little frustrating for her.
But anyways, that's what you do. Now,
the next piece of this question was
for alertness throughout the day.
What do you do to stay
alert throughout the day?
I think one of the things you
gotta do is check your diet, right?
Check the Diet, make sure, in my opinion,
make sure you're not ingesting a tone
of carbohydrates because those are going
to make you tired.
They're going to make you excited or
make you fired up for about 20 minutes.
I don't know,
haven't had them in a long time for
like 20 minutes before you eat them.
Like right when you actually,
that's really what they're for.
Or currently instant energy. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, and they put you to sleep.
So when when you,
when you eat it,
it's basically the really basic
sequence is I'm going to do some output,
you know, in the wild. I'm going
to go hunting and whatever you,
I'm going to gather whatever,
do some output that expended some energy.
I'm going to need some energy and I'm
going to need some rest. When you get the,
the energy, carbohydrates,
food in any way,
Serotonin, all these other chemicals
that induce you to go rest,
that's the sequence. That's the process.
Don't forget about insulin. Yeah.
Cause the insulin all squared away
then was gonna make you tired too.
So check your diet, check your
dying. I just had a guy on Twitter.
Ah Man, he, he's, he's like, hey man,
I'm tired during the day. I'm dragging.
I was like, well we'll check your diet.
And he's like, well I think it's okay.
I'm drinking a lot of energy drinks.
No,
not good. The energy drinks are
addictive. Yeah, they're tasty.
They're addictive.
And they're,
they're filled with
sugar most of the time.
So you're going to get a major sugar
rush and then you're going to crash.
So you gotta be careful that they also,
you don't want to be on,
on the crazy amount of caffeine all day.
And that's gonna mess up your system as
well. Does the same thing as the sugar,
the caffeine rush, and then the
crash, that's the same thing. Oh yeah.
You have more than sugar. Yeah. In,
in, well, I'll tell you right now,
people ask me all the time and they're
surprised that I work out without
caffeine in the morning. But I'm
telling you, give it a try. Yeah.
Because it'll be harder. Maybe it's
harder for you to get out of bed.
Maybe it's harder for you to get ready.
Maybe it's harder for you to get into
the gym with no caffeine and maybe it's
harder for you to start your
workout with no caffeine,
but once you start the workout,
yeah.
I don't think it's going to be that
big of a deal. Yeah. And if it is good,
make your workout harder. You know, I
don't think it's that big of a deal.
So don't become addicted to the caffeine
and that's going to be cause that can
get problematic. And then, um,
power nap talked about this before. If
you need to, you take a little power nap.
You take six to eight minutes,
you set your alarm clock,
you elevate your feet above your heart.
You lay down and you black out.
If you're really tired,
you six to eight minutes of your feet,
like you feel like a rock
star after one of those. Nope,
I agree in another thing you can do if
you're tired during the day, no big deal.
Just find a little corner somewhere.
Go Bang some pushups out.
Go Bang out 10 burpees. Yeah, I get the
blood flowing and get the blood flowing.
Yeah. There's no way it's, it's,
it's physiologically
impossible to do burpees and,
and remain tired. Whatever. Burpees,
you can tell you since you turned into
a physiology major over here tonight,
if you want to tell me what that
does physiologically, I don't know,
but I do know this. If you knock out
10 burpees, it's a small purse, Paul,
small prescription. You will not be
tired for at least a half an hour.
You're not going to be 10 burpees and
then feel tired. It does. He can't do it.
I can tell you why physiologically
endorphins get released.
This stuff adrenaline, like when you know
you're going to do physical activity,
when you know it, you have
it. I'm not saying a huge
adrenaline, just a little bit,
little, yeah, a little bit.
She's still going part of it.
So that's,
those are some tips I guess for
alertness throughout the day that I use.
Yeah. Go and forgetting that a better
early in the morning. Hey and by the way,
go to bed earlier at night,
go to bed earlier at night.
I go to bed like I'll usually around 11.
Um, I don't recommend that. I don't run.
Recommend going to bed at 11
and getting up at four 30. No,
I don't recommend that. I recommend
going to bed when you get tired,
shut your computer off.
Stop looking at the Inter webs
and go to sleep and you know what?
Go read an actual book because that made
you tired. Yeah, that will make you tie.
That's like the opposite of
burpees. Go read, go read a book,
you know, and just sit there and
you will get more tired. Yeah.
Unless like a real exciting or interesting
book. Whoa. And read some more.
Of course,
of course.
Don't read blood Meridian because
when you go to bed and you're,
cause you're a fast sleeper. Fast sleeper.
Well you don't need that much sleep,
but yeah, yeah, yeah. The no sleep
thing that'll get you so quick.
It'll promptly put you into
a crash the next day. Yeah.
I don't know where you can
power through. Well I dunno. I,
if I can go to the next man. I've even
when you had the latest little baby,
you came in here on a couple hours sleep,
you look rolled in here ready to record.
You sat here, you got after it. Yeah.
It's true. And there's all
these different, does that
make you realize? Yeah.
It makes you realize how much more
you can do. I think a lot of people,
it's like this, and I don't want to
go into this full subject right now,
but the other day I did a 72 hour fast,
right?
No food for 72 hours and there's a
bunch of reasons we could talk about it.
Maybe we'll do it on a later podcast. I
will say this though, one small thing,
if you go 72 hours without eating it
recalibrates your hunger meter because we
just think, oh, I haven't
had a donut in two hours.
I'm starving like, no,
you're not starving.
You're not even hungry and I'm close
to hungry, so recalibrate that thing.
Do a fast.
Even if you just don't eat for 24 hours,
you realize that most of your hunger
signals that are coming to your brain are
lies, and I'm not saying they're
lies like, oh, don't eat,
but I'm saying you don't need to eat.
And how liberating is it that I was,
I was having so much fun. I was, I
was on this fast and I'm just like,
don't even need food. I don't
eat food. I don't need to eat.
That's the ultimate control,
right? What I don't need food,
food is food is for fruit is if
you're weak. You know what I mean?
It's that of you get that mentality
going in. Then guess what?
Now you go on a travel day and you go,
Oh man,
I'm going to be in the airport all day
today and I dunno what I'm going to eat.
Don't eat anything. Yep, you're capable.
You're totally, you can go 72 hours.
As a matter of fact,
you can go 30 days without food.
So going three days is not that big of a
deal. It's not even that big of a deal.
Yeah,
I did when I just did this 72 hour fast.
He was just not like I did
everything normal. I went to
Jujitsu, I did worked out,
I did squats and pull ups. Everything
was normal, everything was normal.
It's not that big crazy deal.
Just we just get so accustomed to to
just feed the machine all the time.
And you could have a,
you know,
you've got to have a meal every six hours
and it's so at our fingertips. It's so,
but it's also you.
This is what I realized is so inconvenient
to have to eat all I know man.
You know flack.
You're right.
So it's kind of Nice to just eating
know once a day this happened. Boom,
put a big old steak on and get after
it. Yeah, I mean, and again, I hate,
there's all kinds of people mean
there's people that know this is,
this is one of the reasons I don't like
talking about this particular topic, um,
is cause there's,
there's a lot of people didn't like study
this and know a bunch about this Nepal,
all these facts.
So if I go and do the research,
well I know the facts too, but I don't, I
can't, I'm considering quote them. Right.
I don't have the in depth knowledge
that Peter a Tiaa has on fasting.
You know what I mean? Or Dom D'agostino,
those guys, their Ph, they're doctors.
I'm not a doctor. I'm a knucklehead.
That was, and another thing is people,
you know, what did you do to prepare for
your faster? I was like, oh, I didn't eat.
Yeah,
I was,
I was with leaf and we were on a trip
and we had like a lunch and then we did a
Gig that night and I don't
like to eat before I do a gig.
And then after that we stayed up a little
bit and did some work and then woke up
in the morning at an early flight. And
then I came home and I wanted to train.
So I worked out and I got done with
that and I went and did something else.
And next thing I knew it was
24 hours, I guy, you know what?
And the next day I didn't feel too
hungry. So I was, I just held on.
So it wasn't no preparation,
just got after it. Again,
people don't do this anecdotal check with
a physician or whatever you gotta do.
Don't listen to me.
Yeah.
As far as like a recommendation you should
do because you know you are different
and 17 hour fast, hey Dee, I dig it man.
But I think really kind of the point that
you're making or one of them anyway I
think is absolutely true.
So you're, you know,
a lot of it is habitual hunger, but it
goes beyond just like psychological,
habitual. It's like
physiological. It's like, okay,
I'm used to getting food every four hours.
So when the four hour mark comes
around physiologically, your,
your stomach going to be like,
word of my food. Yeah. Your,
you're malting me where my food. And
then after a while, if you're like, hey,
you don't get food this time, your songs,
you're okay. Sometimes we don't get food.
Yeah. So let's kind of act right. You
know? And then when the food comes, okay,
we'll do that.
When that happened,
recalibration is real low because then
after I started eating again and then the
next day I go, oh, I'm, I'm feeling
hungry. I'm gonna eat something now.
I'm actually not hungry, so
why am I eating? Why am I
eating if I'm not hungry? Mm.
Yeah. That's, it's my mind is controlling
me when I should be controlling my mind.
Yeah. You know, so, and that's another
thing where, um, you're, you're, uh,
this nothing new, right. Your
mind is so strong or whatever,
so you can trick yourself into schools.
For sleep too.
So if you think that you
got nine hours of sleep,
you'll be way less tired then. Okay.
Let's say two people, exact people,
they're identical twins, identical
life experience, whatever.
One guy believes the next morning
they both got eight hours sleep.
One guy believes he only got four hours
sleep and one guy believes he got 10
hours sleep placebo scenario.
Yeah,
but that's how your mind it knows like
basically it's your mind accommodating
what it thinks the stimulus
is. So, so the other twin,
the four hour sleep believer,
he's going to be way more tired
and he's gonna be like, Dang,
where's that nap I was looking forward,
I need or whatever the other one.
Imagine if you woke up
every day and you were like,
I only got four hours of sleep and
I'm going to crush to exactly right.
I actually believe I work better on
less sleep. How you like them apples.
Exactly, exactly. And that's, that's
what was going to be my point there.
Where you're like, you told you, I've
told you that before. Yeah, I've, I've,
so I've told the echo before that
when we're getting ready to record the
podcast, the day before I
record the podcast, that night,
I like to sleep less like four hours
because I feel like it sharpens,
I'll tell you what, to be quite
honest, what I think it does, it,
it brings it,
it brings my emotions a
little closer to the surface.
So like you feel like we're, I'm kind
of under attack, so I better wait.
I bet are like,
pardon up right now.
I better like get my two notes that
it's like, no, this is what it is.
I can get more. Like when I'm reading
something, I'm more focused on it.
I'm more into it, like
actively, like, yeah. Because
I think when I'm well rested,
I'm like, like, uh, like rock solid,
right? I'm just like, Oh yeah, we're not,
the went on a little where I sleep less,
I'm a little bit more exposed.
I'm a little bit more vulnerable.
Right. Mentally. Right.
And I need that, right. Because
otherwise I'd just become very,
mmm mmm.
Detached. I become very
detached and it's, it's, I know.
So I want it when I come in here,
I want to be on though.
I want to be on the fringe a little
bit. Right. You know what I mean?
That's what I want to be exposed. I want
to be walking in here and being like,
man, this is going to be, this
is an intense, this thing,
not a walk in the park today. This
is going to be hard to let me. Yes.
I want to be stressed a little bit. When
I come in here, I can dig it and I feel,
I always feel that way.
Like it's the same thing in Jujitsu.
I feel better when I'm stressed and
when I'm a little bit more, yeah,
a little bit more stressed,
a little bit more attention,
a little bit more pressure on myself.
I want to be there,
don't want to be there all the time.
And I'll tell you what,
just so everybody knows,
there's some days I'm tired
where I'm just tired and I just,
sometimes I just need a power
nap so bad at Mocad I'm going up,
I'm literally falling asleep,
you know? And I hate that.
That's a horrible feeling,
which, you know what? Elevate
your feet. Set an alarm clock
for eight minutes, boom,
you're going to wake
up field next superman.
It's Kinda like when people hit
themselves before they go live because it
weighed, you mean they're like
slap themselves. Yeah, for sure.
So on the surface it looks like,
oh, he's getting fired up, but yeah.
Why is he getting fired up for the exact
same reason that you're talking about?
Because if it's like [inaudible] like
I'm getting these things where I got to
kind of bounce back from,
right. I'm under attack.
Legitimate root adrenaline rush
too. Right. So physiologic.
That's the same exact
sequence right there.
But you're just doing it consciously
and instead of slaps it's lack of sleep.
Yes.
Or what have you.
There you go. That's um, yeah.
Answer in. Everyone's going to attack
me on social media for not sleeping,
not eating and all that. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, sorry, I don't know what
to tell you. What? Hey tacos.
I appreciate your advice. I know I
should. I do know I should sleep more.
I do know I should eat, you know
better. Oh, I'm sorry. Well,
what does that even mean? Should the
word should, what does that even mean?
You should, it's, yeah. Anyway, that's the
whole [inaudible] don't be you anymore.
Well that's true. Be Different
than you. That's what that, well,
I actually actually the point,
oh,
what I was gonna say earlier is
just like what you're saying,
the f like you're not citing all this
science and making claims about like how
this is going to benefit you or nothing
like that. That's not what you're doing.
It's,
it is anecdotal.
And I think the point is that if you
push yourself through certain situations
and you prove it to yourself that you can
function just fine with, I don't know,
five hours sleep rather than eight
one or two times or whatever,
or however many you know that you
can do that. Like really, you know,
we'd talked about this before where you
get kind of dependent on certain things
and then to the point where you believe
that you can't function without it.
Whether it be sleep, whether it be coffee
in the morning, w w you know, whatever.
Or eating every four hours.
Like when I was really into like
weightlifting and bodybuilding type stuff,
I remember thinking, man, I
gotta, I gotta hurry up and eat.
It's four hours or whatever. And then kind
of later on in life, man, I've got like,
I haven't eaten yet today and
it's late in the day. I'm fine,
you're not, I'm not losing my gaze.
Yeah, whatever games. But Games game,
whatever. Yeah. So once
you prove it to yourself,
it's like if you stay up all night when
you have work the next day and you do
your work when you go to bed you
can be like, hey, if I had to,
I could do that again.
That is another thing that I enjoy about
pushing those envelopes is it feels
really good to go to bed when
you've been awake for a long time.
It feels really good to eat a meal
once you haven't eaten for for awhile.
You appreciate it more. Yeah,
that's good. That's true.
But that's kind of a cycle
wave of invoking appreciation.
In my opinion.
Understood.